[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using probably
for about a year now peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on-demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on demand and listen to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and
over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda-yadda-yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way incentivize me but they really
100% hit the nail on the head I was very
very impressed with how motivating it
was
and work tremendously to keep me pushing
which quite honestly takes a fair amount
I can get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me
so check it out discover this cutting
edge indoor cycling bike that brings the
studio experience right to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
podcast a limited time offer go to one
peloton calm that's o-n-e peloton PE l
oto and.com and enter the code Tim all
caps at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your policy on bike
purchase so get a great workout at home
anytime you want check it out go to one
peloton calm and use the code Tim to get
started this episode is brought to you
by LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as well
WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg
now valued at more than a billion
dollars have used LegalZoom to help with
their business needs specifically in his
case to form his company but LegalZoom
isn't just for launching your business
their services include everything from
helping you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating NDA's
non-disclosure agreements important
stuff handling lease agreements and
assisting with really any other legal
challenge hurdle inconvenience that
typically takes time and effort away
from running your business the best part
is that you won't get charged by the
hour
because Legal Zoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get ala carte style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com
and enter promo code to him
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job each
episode to interview and deconstruct
world-class performers and/or people who
are the best at what they do
to tease out the life lessons habits
tools and so on that you can hopefully
apply to your own lives and this episode
was such a treat for me I it's so much
fun and I was able to interview a living
legend someone I've wanted to interview
in this podcast for many years stanislav
grof and we went deep
we went long we went wide it was
everything I hoped it to be stanislav
grof m.d. otherwise known as stan grof
stanislav spelled STA and is La Vie is a
psychiatrist with more than 60 years of
experience in research of holotropic
states of consciousness and will define
what that means in the interview but
suffice to say for now it is a large and
important subgroup of non-ordinary
states that have healing transformative
and evolutionary potential and we will
explore all of that previously he was
principal investigator in a psychedelic
research program at the psychiatric
Research Institute in Prague
Czechoslovakia chief of psychiatric
research at the Maryland psychiatric
Research Center assistant professor of
psychiatry at Johns Hopkins University
in Baltimore Maryland and scholar in
residence at the Esalen Institute in
this very wide-ranging conversation we
cover a whole lot of things including
some stuff that he has not gone over
previously so among others some of his
main takeaways after supervising or
guiding roughly 4,500 LSD sessions that
is LSD assisted psychotherapy sessions
the place and role of so called wounded
healers limitations and uses of
traditional psychoanalysis and talk
therapy similarities are some
similarities between holotropic
breathwork and MDMA use or the
applications of MDMA stories of very odd
synchronicities and the seemingly
impossible we get into some very very
hard to explain reports and phenomena to
put it very very lightly
Stan's strangest personal experiences on
cycle
and what Stan believes humanity most
needs to overcome division and
destruction currently stan is professor
of psychology at CI is that's the
California Institute of integral studies
in San Francisco and conducts
professional training programs and
holotropic breathwork and transpersonal
psychology as well as gives lectures and
seminars worldwide he is one of the
founders and chief theoreticians of
transpersonal psychology as a field and
the founding president of the
International transpersonal Association
ITA
his publications include more than 150
articles in professional journals and
books like psychology of the future the
cosmic game and holotropic breathwork
among many others you can find him
online and I will link to this and
everything in this episode in the show
notes at Tim da blog forward slash
podcast you can find them online at
stanislav grof
dot-com now one more thing before we get
to the interview and I'll try to keep
this short please please please if
you're a listener of this podcast if you
like what you hear
I invite you and ask you please to
subscribe to the podcast and you will
get notified whenever I release a new
episode for many reasons and a lot of
technical reasons this is very very
helpful to me in my podcast team it
helps us to get hard-to-reach guests and
do much more takes 10 to 30 seconds so
all you have to do is search for the Tim
Ferriss show you can misspell it doesn't
matter in iTunes or on your phone in the
app you use like Apple podcasts overcast
stitch your cast box whatever when you
see my face and the Tim Ferriss show
click on it and click subscribe that's
it super easy if you can spare the 10 to
30 seconds thank you for pausing this
episode briefly to do that it really
helps us to do bigger and better things
for you all and with that said please
enjoy this interview I hope you enjoy it
as much as I did with the one and only
Stan Grof
Stan welcome to the show thank you very
much Tim thank you for having me it's
nice that I would like to thank you for
everything you have been doing for
raising consciousness on this planet
it's been amazing and it's a great honor
and pleasure for me to be on your show
oh thank you so much I could not be more
excited to be speaking with you right
now and we said hello via video just a
few moments ago and I certainly have
only become more excited to have this
conversation because of our our
introduction jack Kornfield one of the
sweetest humans I know and I have many
questions and many topics so thanks of
course to Jack for making the
introduction and by this time people
would have already heard some of your
bio graphical information that I would
have read but I suppose we should start
maybe at the beginning and ask you how
you first became interested in
psychedelics well the situation was I
became initially very excited about
psychoanalysis and as a result of it I
went to medical school and in my fourth
year of medical school I was going to
the psychiatric department already as a
volunteer to get some you know some
sense for that for the discipline and
this is where we got from Santos a
supply of ampules of delis it of LSD and
it came with a letter talking about the
history about you know the famous
experienced self experiment of Albert
Hofmann and the bicycle ride and all
that and they were asking us if we would
like to experiment with that substance
and let them know if there was any
legitimate use for it in psychiatry and
psychology and my preceptor not sent
robichek who this was very interested
in LSD but he didn't have time to sit
you know for six or eight hours with his
patients with the experimental subjects
so he was using several of us as kind of
golfers we were sitting in these
sessions and we were keeping the records
so I actually started my exposure to LSD
already 1954 but unlike at Harvard
students were excluded so I couldn't
have my own session until I graduated
from the medical school and by the time
you know my appetite was wetted so I was
sitting in these sessions of
psychologists psychiatrists artists and
you know hearing all these fantastic
stories about the experiences that they
had but I had no really no access to it
what application were you looking at
initially what was what was the
destruction you know initially it was
just just the kind of a it was just a
phenomenological research that's giving
it to different people and seeing what
it does you know I don't know if you can
imagine now when there are a lot of
publications and you know other kinds of
publicity what it was like for us when
this substance fell into our laps we had
absolutely no idea what it would do you
know from session to session I mean we
didn't know where it would be going you
know with our patients and in our own
sessions so it was quite an exciting
adventure I spent several years actually
doing two sessions a day I would get up
early if do a session and talk two
o'clock you know I started another one
and I had a department where I had 18
beds and all the patients were getting
LSD so they were really familiar with
the states and all our nurses had
training sessions so by two o'clock I
could pass the the person I was coming
down from an LSD session to this team of
nurses and and patients and I could
start another one
and I was sitting in all of those
sessions you know all the whole time
unlike some other places where for
example
ants car-o-liner he was actually leaving
the experimental subjects alone and they
just had a bell where they could call a
nurse when they were in trouble but I
was so excited about what was coming and
I realized this was this is going to
change you know
psychiatry psychology what what was it
about those early experiences that led
you to that conclusion that it would
change psychiatry and psychology and
maybe just before we get to that and and
I want to talk about your first
experience as well but how many total
sessions have you directly or indirectly
been a part of our supervisor with in
your life would you say at this point
would be like a four and a half thousand
of you know velocity sessions but I had
also I was working with psilocybin oh so
we were working for a while with the
tryptamine derivatives which actually
came from Budapest from our neighbor dr.
Zara Steven Zahra and dr. Besser Amin
they were the ones who actually
developed the whole group of the
tryptamine derivatives DMT det DPT it I
don't think they had at the time the
methoxy DMT which seems to be the most
most interesting one and the the initial
feeling that you that you had or the the
initial suppose excitement that you felt
this could change psychology and
psychiatry why was that what did you see
that made you come to that conclusion
well the initial was this you know
approach which could be called search
for toxin X the way LSD came to us was
that is a substance that can mimic
somehow a psychosis
we call the initial sessions
experimental psychosis you know it's
called a Lucy no Jane's a psycho to
memetic and so the excitement was that
we have a model of something like
schizophrenia or the other other kinds
of psychosis and this made a possibility
of creating a model which is always
great to have a model in in science so
give
LSD you know to quote-unquote normal
subjects and they would spend six to
eight hours in a world that seemed to be
like the world of our patients and so
the initial my initial research actually
was laboratory I wrote one of the early
papers on the role of serotonin in in
psychiatry and the initial research was
we had a group of 40 people including
ourselves
mostly professional psychologists
psychiatrists biologists and so on and
we had a protocol we would invite these
people for a day to the research
institute we would do really scientific
work you know drawing blood every hour
on the hour collecting samples of urine
doing psychological tests and and
electrophysiological investigations and
then we had one day when we brought
schizophrenic patients who were matched
by h by by gender by IQ and so on with
our experimental subjects and we were
looking if these values of this
psychological and physiological
biochemical tests would sort of converge
with the values in schizophrenic s-- and
then something amazing happened i found
that there was incredible
I would say inter-individual
intra-individual variability so you give
the same substance in the same dosage
under the you know same circumstances
under the same lousy set and setting
which we had and each of those people
would have different experiences to the
point that some of them called it like
the moments that they get between the
tests it was like self analysis like you
know drug assisted psychotherapy others
were just unpleasant physical symptoms
some of them had to know paranoid
episodes or became hypomanic and for
some of them
it was that they even under those
circumstances that got glimpses of
ecstatic states that that were very
mystical and the same intra-individual
variability if we took the same
substance at different times this
phenomenology was completely different
and at that point I realized this was
not psychopharmacology we were not doing
pharmacology because if you do
pharmacology you have to have some idea
what you are getting you know if you
give people up on morphine you expect
that a lot of them will be vomiting if
you give them hypnotic you expect them
to sleep whereas here we had no idea
what would happen so I realized we were
doing something much more interesting we
were we had a catalyst that was make
made it possible to explore the depths
of the human psyche I realized people
were not having LSD experiences they
were having experiences of themselves
but they were coming from depths that
you know psychoanalysis didn't know
anything about and so at that point I
just lost completely interest in this
laboratory approach and I took it to the
clinical Oracle and I started giving to
my patients you know in a
psychotherapeutic context when did you
have your first personal experience it
was how much and what did I take and how
much did you take if you recall this was
actually a hundred hundred micrograms it
was on the 13th of November 1956 so I
was from 54 56 I was sitting for people
but it was a little more complicated
because my preceptor whom I mentioned
earlier he was very interested in
electroencephalography and at the time
when LSD came he was the one who
received it from Sandoz so at the time
when it came he was interested in
something that's called driving the
brainwaves or an in training the
brainwaves
using EEG well it was exposing people to
a very powerful stop of scopic light
frequencies and finding out if the brain
waves in the suboccipital area which is
the visual cortex if the brain waves
will pick up that frequency if you can
drive them or train the brain wave so
the condition for for us having this
session with him
we had to agree that we would have EEG
you know before during and after and
that we also will have our brain waves
driven in in all those sessions so what
happened that you know between the third
and the fourth hour when the session
usually culminated the dr. Robey checks
assistant came and she said it's time to
drive the brainwaves so she took me to a
little room I laid down she pasted all
these electrodes on my head and then
brought this gigantic strobe put it
above my head and then turn this thing
on and in the next moment there was
light like I had never seen I couldn't
even imagine existed my only concept
there was this is what it must have been
like in Hiroshima where the thing went
off you know today I think it was more
like dharmakaya day the primary clear
light from Bardo thodol from the Tibetan
Book of the Dead that we see at the
moment of our deaths but what happened
is my consciousness was catapulted out
of my body
I lost the research assistant you know I
lost the clinic I lost Prague I lost the
planet and I had the feeling that I
actually stopped extinguished in in the
form that I knew myself but also the
sense that I somehow became everything
there was I became all of all of
existence as you know we must have heard
it quite a few times that these states
are considered ineffable it's when you
start trying to describe them is used
I doubt that we just simply don't have
don't have language our language is
developed you know to communicate about
things from from everyday life and in my
later experiments some of the
sophisticated patients actually tried to
use a language from cultures that knew
something about consciousness like using
you know from from Hinduism from you
know Tibetan Buddhism from Taoism so
they were talking about you know
nirvikalpa samadhi Islamic culpa Suvari
kensho Satori you know using terms like
Maya and so on because we simply don't
have you know technical terms for for
these states so these experiences of
mystical States are full of paradoxes
paradoxically tea is one of the
characteristics so you can have the
feeling that you became nothing but by
becoming nothing you actually became of
existence so I was in this incredible
state and then as she was continuing
working with me it was unfolding
she had a protocol so she started from
two Hertz which is you know two
frequencies per second took it up to
sixty and then she kept it for a while
in the Alpha range and that theta range
the Delta range and then she turned it
off and why she was doing this at a
certain point I actually went from this
sense of being everything of being in
the universe in the astronomical
universe or or actually being the
universe there were things happening for
which at the time I didn't have names
but then later I read about you know the
Big Bang and the black holes and the
wormholes and so this was something in
that category that was happening to me I
actually had the feeling again that I
not was not only in the universe but I
actually was the universe and then you
know as she turned it off then my world
started shrinking again
I found the planet I found Prague zoomed
in on my body but there was a major
problem because my consciousness was
actually kind of circling around my body
and I had difficulties aligning my
consciousness with my body so at that
point it became clear to me that what
they were teaching it universities about
consciousness as a product of the brain
simply was nonsense that you know
consciousness was something cosmic and
that the brain somehow is a moderator
for that but it's not generated in in
our skull could you and finally I
managed to align that and I came down in
a very ecstatic state very impressed
what just happened and right there I
decided if I'm a psychiatrist
you know this is by far the most
interesting thing I can do working with
these with these states it just
overshadowed psychoanalysis like you
know I was not interested in
psychoanalysis anymore I was interested
in exploring the psyche using these
states so you you've at this point
dedicated more than six decades to
studying non-ordinary states of
consciousness which is I think we'll
probably talk about this that is a term
or a phrase you prefer over altered
states of consciousness but you're
you're alluding to perhaps a definition
of consciousness or how you think about
it now how do you think about
consciousness at this point you said
that it's I think mediated or moderated
by the brain but not generated by it
based on these experiences the
experiences of others you've supervised
everything you've you've seen and
experienced and studied up to this point
how do you think about consciousness now
are there any other aspects of you know
I'm very close now to every lászló who
is this brilliant systems theorist and
philosophers of Hungarian origin
but living in Pisa in Italy and he has a
series of books were easily addressing
these problems he's the only one that I
think found some way of scientifically
describing what is happening to us and
he has a book called what is reality
where he actually goes through these
different experiments that we have
related to consciousness and argues you
know what what are the observation that
we have against the idea that that
consciousness is local that is inside of
our brain and he moves to that
consciousness is more transpersonal that
it in non-ordinary States you can have
experiences of consciousness of other
people you can have experiences of of
being in becoming members of a different
species you know and not just animals
but also plants and so on so he moves
from that from the consciousness being
local to consciousness being
transpersonal and then he brings even
arguments again that and concludes that
that consciousness is cosmic and you
know that would be that would be my
present understanding the consciousness
is simply a part of integral part of
existence it cannot be reduced to to
anything else let alone the neurons in
the in the brain so this also supported
now of course by many people from
quantum relativistic physics and for
example Stuart Hameroff initially
thought that maybe it's the so called
tubules in the mitochondria in the in
the brain but might be the place where
some quantum processes generate
consciousness and then later he sort of
took it back and he says now according
to him consciousness is simply property
of the universe that can be traced back
to the Big Bang in the form of proto
consciousness there's a term that people
often associate of course rightly with
you in association with consciousness
and that is
holotropic states of consciousness and
I'd love to to jump into that because
and also just as a side note for people
listening who are wondering what the
applications of these these non-ordinary
states might be or how they've been
utilized there are men it appears to me
that there are many many different ways
to utilize this there's certain multiple
Nobel Prizes associated with it Kary
Mullis Francis Crick and the code
discovery of the double helix and then
there are you know well-known
entrepreneurs and so on like Steve Jobs
but what does holotropic refer to a
whole topic state of consciousness thank
you great great question well I have so
far been or we have been using the term
non-ordinary states of consciousness
which is better that one about
psychiatrist British and American
psychiatrists are doing calling it
altered state you know I really dislike
that term although it was coined by a
good friend of my Charlie turret because
it suggests somehow that there is a
correct way of experiencing ourselves
and the world and that somehow disturbed
you know I always have to think about
veterinary medicine we talked we had our
dog altered so I feel too much respect
for these days to call them altered and
even the state non-ordinary is really
not accurate because there are many
non-ordinary states that have not the
properties that the holotropic states
would have so I use the term holotropic
for a special large subcategory of
non-owner states that have healing
potential therapeutic potential that
have according to my experience
transformative potential that have what
we call Urist ik h EU r which means when
you work with these states you've run
into a lot of paradigm breaking
observations that challenge the whole
way of thinking not just in psychiatry
but in realistic science and then I
believe they also have evolutionary in
other words day but I think they would
if people would systematically use them
I think we will almost become another
and other species you know
people work through a lot of aggression
it's replaced by compassion they have
the experience of tremendous ecological
sensitivity they they discover that we
are deeply embedded in nature and that
we cannot do anything to nature that
doesn't damage us they start seeing
violence as an unacceptable way of
solving problems you know they have a
sense of being actually global citizens
rather than being texts or Russians or
Americans they start seeing themselves
very much the way it happened to the
astronaut who with the possibility of
actually seeing the the planet from from
the moon or from space so this is my
term that I coined because I realized
psychiatry does not have that kind of
distinction
so I'd coined it myself it's a kind of a
verbal hybrid it's a neologism as we
call it that comes from the Greek
language where hallows means hole and
trap or trap pain means moving in the
direction of something I usually refer
to the world Helia trapeze and Helios
means son and heliotropism is the
property of plans to always orient
themselves towards the Sun always
followed the Sun so literally this means
moving toward wholeness you know when I
when I used that term there's usually
somebody who say what do you mean moving
toward wholeness and we're all already
the way we function in everyday life and
I would have to say no on the basis of
my experiences we have are we using only
small fraction of our experience or
potential when we are in the ordinary
States so maybe I just give a few
examples of autotrophic States or people
ever sense what I'm talking about yes
please
so one category when you would find
states that I call holotropic would be
the initiatory crisis of shamans you
know the carrier of most shamans
begin by a spontaneous experience of
traveling into the visionary experience
of traveling into the universe being a
traveling into the the underworld first
they have the experience of being
exposed to some ordeals we experience a
lot of emotional physical pain and they
experience annihilation and then
experience of psycho spiritual death
rebirth that's followed by this journey
into the supernal realms and in this
initiatory journey they heal themselves
typically anthropologists call shamans
the wounded healers and they also learn
how to heal so when they then manage to
come back and they ground the session
they use holotropic States in their
healing when they here they either go
into a non-ordinary stay or they induce
them in their clients or both shamans
and clients get into this holotropic
States so that's a major category the
second one is what you see in so-called
rites of passage this is the term that
was coined by a Dutch anthropologist are
not one Hannett that's GE and an EP who
studied many native cultures and he
found out that they all you know at the
time of important biological or social
transitions perform very powerful
rituals when they also induce in these
holotropic States in different ways many
of those cultures even with psychedelic
plants or psychedelic psychedelic
materials in some others using you know
sonic technology
drumming Rhett link and so on
physical pain stay in the desert stay in
the high mountains stay in a cave in the
Arctic ice and so on and if you study
these the people experience psycho
spiritual death rebirth very much like
the shamans in their spontaneous
initiatory journey another third
important character
with the ancient mysteries of death
rebirth like the Eleusinian mysteries
store the Isis Osiris mysteries in Egypt
or the Sumerian mysteries of Inanna and
Dumuzi and also in Odaiba they were
Mesoamerican mysteries of Shiv Baba the
Mayan and so on so all these were
inducing these holotropic States for
healing and transformation and then also
all the major religions developed what I
call technologies of the sacred you know
different forms of yoga different
schools of Buddhism from tera vaada to
to Zen and Vajrayana Taoist exercises in
the Christian tradition helices and the
Jesus Prayer or the Exercises of
Ignatius Saint Ignatius of Loyola its
various cabbalistic Kabbalistic
exercises so those are all methods that
were designed to take people into these
holotropic experiences for the purpose
of of having a mystical experience
having a spiritual experience and of
course we have now modern technologies
of the sacred to induce holotropic
experiences we have now pure alkaloids
from from the psychedelic plants you
know we have eskalene from peyote we
have Salah scene and psilocybin from the
magic mushrooms of the Damaso text we
have now the iboga in from from iboga
from from the African African bush and
so on and we also have now the
tryptamine derivatives DMT DPT and then
methoxy the empty those are active in
ayahuasca and in the different snuffs
from the Caribbean and also from this
Tord that's now becoming very famous
befo before al-bari use these are
secretions from the parotid glands and
from the skin of these toads very very
powerful very important psychedelics so
let me pause for one second I have many
I'm not gonna lose track of the Train
and I have a number of different
questions but since since you brought it
up a mutual friend of ours different
mutual friend had suggested I ask you
about toad and you just mentioned that
it's it could be or is important and you
mentioned methoxy DMT which you know in
this case often refer to in five Meo DMT
what are your thoughts on this
particular this particular compound and
then why is it important if it's
important well I think is it has not
really been explored scientifically
unlike psilocybin or LSD but we have an
enormous amount of information from
either semi legal or illegal you know
underground experiments which were
happening during those years when psyche
that is we're not really explored
scientifically but we have an amazing
book by Ralph Matzner which is called
the toad and the Jaguar Ralph traveled
all over Europe and in United States
visiting these groups that were using it
you know either using some legal
loopholes or you know doing a kind of an
underground research and he wrote this
book where he collected that information
in a in a way that could become a basis
of scientific research now what is
fantastic there is that this substance
creates a very short you know within an
hour which is within the time of one
cycle psychoanalytic session you can
experience significant transformation
even even spiritual opening
and the the substance is methoxy DMT I
have in my book when the impossible
happens a chapter which is called the
secret of the toad of light there are
churches in the American Southwest that
are actually using it as a sacrament
called you know Church of the toad of
light and I took fairly large doses
which is not just more than is usually
used this was my first time when we
really didn't know I didn't know the
dosing and it was estimated 25
milligrams today you would use like five
or ten and this was my by far the most
powerful psychedelic experience I've
ever had and within seconds you know it
took me out of my body and ever no
there's nothing biographical no no birth
experience is no nothing archetypal I
was just facing this incredible
I mean source of light you know for the
for the lack of a better description it
was like beyond anything I could imagine
in terms of the the brilliance the
incandescence that it had but also sense
that this there was incredible
intelligence creative intelligence was
going beyond any dichotomies I couldn't
say for demonic or divine you know that
was just off the scales that I had and
then coming down from that experience I
actually had the feeling I was dying but
the feeling that I was not from life
into dying but from a place beyond death
into a dying body and then after a while
it became clear that this was not really
dying it was just the experience of
dying and for quite a while I was in a
situation where I was in an absolutely
blissful kind of State and I was having
visions of streams of my past life
experiences where I had feeling of you
know dying and being killed
in different situations my body was kind
of acting out the agony was shaking
twitching by you know psychologically
emotionally I was in in absolute bliss
and then coming down for a week I was in
a state in which I would like to live we
were at the time living at Esalen we had
a deck overlooking the ocean and this
was the time when I was Henry I think my
my manuscripts and they giving it to a
secretary and then having to edit it and
I was in that week I was doing editing
of my manuscript which I could do
perfectly lying in the Sun there and
then I felt I would take a little break
again within seconds I had the feeling
of just oneness with the whole
environment oneness with the world and
then I would open my eyes and I could
continue editing but then of course you
know the sort of the consciousness of
the industrial civilization came back
you know had to do workshops travel you
know so I didn't stay in that in that
state but my meditations became much
much much deeper and it was not
difficult to get into some version of
that state you know just through
meditation so I think this would be an
amazing amazing substance to try for
practical reasons because you you will
not find psychiatrists like myself in
the you know in the 60s and so on
sitting for six hours with their
patients but they could certainly do a
one hour session with the methoxy DMT
and I think significant therapy could be
done you know with in this very short
short terms it's also according to Ralph
mecaenas observations it's a substance
where the experience ends very cleanly
there is no sort of lingering on so
there is a very powerful experience but
also a good
good closure so anyway so this is my
experience with methoxy DMT now it's
called it's very very popular for
example here the transversal conference
in Prague you know and there were
lectures about it and of course there
were there were people who had access to
the to the toad material to the
excretions or secretions of the glands
so it's becoming a very very popular
popular substance right now you
mentioned therapy a few times in
describing your experience with five Meo
DMT and the potential say within a
one-hour window or something like that
to provide therapy if someone were
sitting for someone experiencing this
and that I want to tie that into a
comment that you're very famous for
having made I think it was in your first
book in 1975 realms of the human
unconscious we're in which you mentioned
the LSD could become for psychiatry what
the microscope was for biology and in
medicine and what the telescope is for
astronomy and what I'm curious about is
I suppose a why you say that but then be
is there still a place for
psychoanalysis you know traditional
psychoanalysis or psychotherapy in
combination with some of these
psychedelic compounds because it's it
seems to me that the perhaps some of the
value that people derive from these
experiences or don't derive from these
experiences is dependent quite a bit on
what happens beforehand and what happens
afterwards but I just I just love to
hear you I suppose clarify what you mean
by LSD becoming first psychiatry with
the microscope is for biology and the
telescope is for astronomy and then be
if therapy still has a place in
combination with these experiences
another wonderful question so let me
tell you what happened when I lost
interest in this laboratory research and
took it to the clinic
we were you mentioned in the in your
interview with Michael Pollan there are
these two forms they've been using LSD
another cycle that is the cycle lytic
and the psychedelic the psychedelic is
that you know using large dose which is
fully internalized with headphones
eyeshades and the method that was used
mostly in Europe but also by some
American therapists
it's called cycle VT which is sort of
dissolving the psyche dissolving the
tensions conflicts in the psyche and so
on from from general Louis's means
dissolution and so I started it with
using sort of medium dosages maybe you
know 150 maybe up to up to 200 at the
beginning and what happened was
absolutely fascinating because and so
intensification of the symptoms that the
patients were having but then the
process automatically took us to the
different layers of traumatic
experiences that were actually
underlying that disorder and a layer
after layer then I came up with the
concept of coax system system of
condensed experience where each symptom
had like a history you know has a series
of layered experiences behind it and so
it was a process of exploring the
different layers of the psyche one of my
patients call it onion peeling of the of
the psyche another one called it chemo
archaeology so you could really explore
the different layers of the postnatal
biographical level this is what what
Freudian analysis is about but the
problem is didn't stop there then each
of those coax systems also had a
contribution from the trauma of birth
suit even if we're using these lower
dosages as we were going on it took us
to birth and that point suddenly people
started experiencing
that they are trapped they're caught
they are in a situation of no exit they
had the feeling they're getting crazy
you know they are dying and so on and
you know my psychiatry and my my
psychotic training did not prepare me
for that kind of thing and it took while
including my own experience history lies
there was a powerful record of
biological birth in there so what we
activated actually in the psyche was
what I call now self-healing
intelligence of the psyche you see the
the process what aeneas lee was talking
was taking us to the sources of these
emotional and psychosomatic symptoms it
also created automatically mapping of
the psyche so for a while I was just
collecting these reports from the
patient my own records and and people's
as you know descriptions of their
sessions and I was putting it on a map
creating a what I thought was a new map
for site for psychology which would be
and the result of the fact that we had
absolutely new tool like microscope
opened up you know this whole underworld
which we in or micro world which we
didn't know existed and telescopes
discovered new new galaxies that the
astronomers didn't know about so you
know I felt we were discovering the
depths of the of the psyche so in that
sense it was like a microscope or a
telescope but it also was the self
hearing intelligence that that sort of
emerged out of it and do you find now
when I finally got the map together but
yet oh no I was just going to say I
please continue I was just going to just
going to ask about if there are adjunct
therapies or things that you would add
to the beginning the the pre psychedelic
experience or post psychedelic
experience but I don't want to interrupt
your train of thought
welljust I just a couple of sentences so
the new map which I created which I
thought was new had the biographical
level which it shared with
psychoanalysis and current psychiatry
because you know how ever much Freud was
criticized psychiatry accepted his idea
that the newborn is a tabula rasa is a
clean slate there is nothing of interest
psychology psychiatry that precedes
birth and this was a major discovery
there is a powerful powerful record of
birth and when you become of aware of
that fact you have to radically change
transform thinking in in psychiatry so
this new new map or map that I thought
was new had the biographical level that
it shared was with current psychiatry
but then I had to add the level which I
called perinatal which is related to
Burris it's a record of birth and then
it opened up further into the level that
I call transpersonal now and there's a
greater overlap with what Jung described
as the collective unconscious the
historical and the the archetypal
unconscious but you see when I had the
map I realized this was not a new map at
all actually a map that in different
forms has been around for not for him
for centuries but for millennia I
started seeing the connection to the
great spiritual philosophies of the east
of Hinduism Buddhism Taoism
you know Sufism and so on and even the
shamanic maps there was a lot of
overlapping with the with the shamanic
cartography so I haven't forgotten your
original question about psychoanalysis
now the problem is that psychoanalysis
has this very narrow map limited to
postnatal biography into the individual
unconscious which is just barely
scratching the surface of what the
psyche really is so if you would
do psychoanalysis you would have to
expand the conceptual framework very
very radically because otherwise if you
would get to something like perinatal
experiences or or transpersonal
experiences you would not have any map
if you use just Freudian for the in
psychoanalysis so it's not it's not the
question of the technique I think in my
understanding
Freud was actually in right on the right
track he was asking questions like why
do we have
you know hysteria why do we have phobias
why do we have obsessive-compulsive
neuroses why do we have perversions and
so on
he was tracing it back but unfortunately
his map was very superficial he did not
have access to the to the perinatal
level to the transpersonal level so he
ended up with conclusions that then
sometimes seemed absurd you know like
suicide is killing the interjected bad
breast of your mother and so on and then
there was a tendency just to move away
completely and not ask the questions but
etiology that Freud's genius was trying
to understand you know why do we have
certain kinds of symptoms why do we have
anxiety why do we have depression why do
we have suicidal tendencies and so on
and was looking for a rational
understanding for this but he took it
only not even halfway had he had access
to the perinatal level he would have
gotten much more convincing
understanding why do we have depression
different forms of depression why what
what does it mean when people would want
to kill themselves in a way that is
nonviolent as compared to people who
have the tendency to commit violence
suicide and so on so if you expand the
cartography and you you add the
perinatal level and the transpersonal
level you can continue this like one
take work actually and get you know some
reasonable quite convincing answers why
do we have certain kinds of symptoms why
do they cluster in what we call
syndromes and so on and it also opens up
a new radically different approaches to
psychotherapy which would be would have
to be experiential if the roots of
emotional problems are not just
postnatal but also perinatal and
transpersonal you cannot reach it by
talking you would have to actually use
experiencial psychotherapy of the kind
that started in the in the 60s the
developed within humanistic humanistic
psychology but let's let's go directly
to that and they certainly have we're
going to come back to when the
impossible happens we're going to come
back to many different pieces of your
past experience and and more recent
projects but this experiential
psychotherapy in in in an ideal world
based on all of your experience what
would that look like what would the
format look like well we are talking
about psychedelics so one would be
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy when
you know people would have sessions and
then you would use talking helping them
to integrate helping them to understand
so there would be you know focus on the
on in the therapy would be on the
experience but also it would be so at
the same time very much what it was for
Freud it would be exploration of the
psyche getting to know the dimensions of
the psyche the the different levels of
experiences in it and so on but now we
have powerful non drug experiences that
can actually take you to those levels to
the perinatal level to the transpersonal
level so my late wife Christine and I
developed what we call holotropic
breathwork where you use very simple
means which is faster breathing some
powerful evocative music a certain kind
of bodywork
and then we also use art we use a
mandala drawing and sharing groups and
people we have access to not just to the
post natal biographical level but also
to the perinatal and to the
transpersonal level so there are you
know there are both pharmacologic and
nonpharmacologic ways of accessing these
levels that have the deepest roots of
emotional and psychosomatic problems so
I'm really glad you brought up
holotropic breathwork which is as you
mentioned a non pharmacological or non
exhaustive a of inducing these
holotropic states which which I've
experienced three times in different
workshops for holotropic breathwork and
I went into it I'm not gonna lie to you
skeptical as someone with psychedelic
experience that it could achieve
anything comparable and I was really
stunned by just how how powerfully you
can induce these these non-owner states
using breath work and what I observed in
other people in the rooms as well who
many of many of which were were
skeptical as I was at the time stitute
to questions to to dig into both the I
suppose psychedelic or and theage in
assisted and then the holotropic
breathwork approach what what
psychedelic materials in what dosages
would you potentially be using with what
frequency would it be once a week twice
a week would it be determined by the
patient would it be psycholytic dosing
or would it be psychedelic dosing how
would you think about that piece I
wouldn't do psycholytic therapy although
I very much value the information that I
got from it you know the self hearing
intelligence of the psyche the coax
systems and and just discovery of the
dimensions
are on that expanded map being taken to
to the perinatal level and then to the
transpersonal level I also have a lot of
interesting observations if you read
ramps of the human unconscious this lot
of it is about trying to understand how
and why the world is changing under the
influence of LSD or some other
psychedelics I became fascinated you
know the people saw me at different
periods of their session as different
things they saw me as a Jaguar they saw
me as it ler they saw me as angel they
saw me as a supreme judge or they look
around the treatment room and sometimes
they had the feeling that they are on
the death Road sometimes cabin in the
Pacific something sometimes it was a
bordello and so on so I did the kind of
Freudian work on it trying to understand
how it condensed you know different
levels of the material so I got a good
understanding of the dynamics of the
postnatal biography but I also found out
that it was not the most effective way
of getting therapy therapeutic results
so then already in Prague I increased
the dosage is I started using music and
and the headphones eyeshades
and this is how we did the whole
research at Spring Grove the American
research when I when I came to the
United States there you can very very
powerful transformation you know within
than six eight hours of the high dose
but you don't have any idea why that
happened you don't understand the
mechanism of the change it resembles the
material that Jonah Rosen described when
he studied the experiences of people who
did suicidal jumps from Golden Gate
Bridge and and the Bateman the bay
bridge he found that people who survived
it which is about 1% they usually
survived it unscathed and they
experienced powerful transformation
within the three
seconds that it took to get from the fro
from the railing to the surface of the
water and then maybe but eight minutes
in cold water before they were rescued
again powerful powerful changes that you
know you wouldn't achieve by years of
psychoanalysis but there was no
understanding what what happened now
with this history of the psycho lytic
their opee I have now some idea about
what is happening in these hydro
stations but in a very condensed very
rapid rapid way so by high dose high
whereas I generally mean sait once more
oh by high dose how many micrograms
would you generally be using okay I
would probably use now dosages like you
know 300 or even 400 400 micrograms
which you know might be in some
instances not very frequently might be a
challenge management of the of the
session but you generally get much more
powerful transformation also cleaner
actually if you use smaller dosages
there is a tendency sometimes to
actually activate what happens and
people have more of a chance to to
resist it if there are air in areas that
they don't want to go into so I consider
the high dosages if there's proper
management to be more effective
therapeutically
so I would use now that smaller dosages
if we continue the this exploration of
the psyche you know that's that's where
lower dosages are certainly very useful
and I'm very sorry that this is not
happening with with psychedelics in this
new renaissance which that we don't
continue the Freudian work where we are
trying to to go to to find what the
roots are trying to understand the
etiology now in this this later DSM the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual they
moved completely from any question of
etiology you know they now just
described the the symptoms they use what
they call New York rebellion
approach emil kraepelin was the the
person who did the first diagnosis in in
psychiatry at the turn of the 19th and
20th century these dementia praecox
which was the original name for
schizophrenia and manic depressive
disorder those whether the first two
diagnoses in psychiatry and what he did
he just simply described the symptoms
that this patients have and now the
tendency in psychiatry is to go to the
neo crap alien like in the dsm you don't
ask the question why do we have
depression why do we have suicidal
tendencies you know why do have
different psychosomatic disorders it's
just simply describing the the symptoms
and i think there is tremendous field of
discovery which would be doing
individual cases like initially in
psychoanalysis you had i think about
1500 psychoanalysts all over the world
who were seeing their patients and they
were they were describing what they
observed and it was published in
journals and so on until they ended up
with the psychoanalytic understanding of
emotional and psychosomatic disorders
you find in auto fennekin's book the
psychotic theory of neurosis so we need
we need to continue that kind of work
this would be something for
psychoanalysis to do you know to
continue Freud's
exploration of the psyche trying to
understand the psyche understand why we
have symptoms and syndromes but not
keeping it just on the on the postnatal
level in the my etiology I think that
was the word that I heard earlier is
that the exploration of the why we
experience yes the cause why do we have
that you know so Freud Freud had the
concept of the development of the libido
the overall phase when these sensual
feelings are associated with nursing and
this was the passive oral and then the
active oral when the the infant starts
biting is the teat and so on and then it
moves
to the anal phase the time to of toilet
training and then refined toilet
training which had to do with urination
that was the urethra station then he
talked about the phallic stage which was
the stage where the focus is on the
under genitals under and the clitoris in
girls and that penis of the boys and
then where you have the arable complex
and you know the castration complex and
all those things which was very very
interesting way of thinking but it
didn't go deep enough so you you ended
up with very unconvincing
interpretations but now I have tried in
my books to continue and see how you
would understand in a much deeper way
why do we have these things and we have
depression different types of depression
suicidal tendencies you know why do we
have symptoms like a headache and and
many many neurotic patients have
problems breathing and so on where does
that come from why do we end up with
psychosomatic pains for which there is
no organic finding so if you expand the
cartography you can really get a much
fuller understanding you know Freud at a
certain point when he discovered the
individual unconscious he compared the
psyche to an iceberg he said what we
thought the psyche was it's just surface
it's like the part of the iceberg that's
showing above the surface and
psychoanalysis shows you also the
submerged part of the iceberg now if you
now bring psychedelics you have to
change them the simile or the metaphor
you would have to say what classical
psychoanalysis discovered it's just
barely the surface it's the part of the
iceberg that's showing for
psychoanalysts and there is this an
enormous part of the psyche that remain
hidden even for for traditional
psychoanalysis Joseph Joseph Campbell I
just let me just assure one sentence
which I cannot resist
Joseph Campbell you know the wonderful
mythologies
this incredible Irish humor he put it
differently he said Freud was fishing
while sitting on a whale the the you've
you have seen so many things experienced
so many things let's just call it
roughly 4,500 different sessions you've
thought of all these different
modalities looking at my very very
limited personal experience and what
I've observed in other people I've I've
certainly seen as you have some
incredible examples of transformation
people who have seemingly resolved
chronic depression or anxiety disorders
eating disorders and and experienced
incredible healing that it seems to have
a persistent effect after experiencing
these deep psychedelic states i've also
observed not a small number of people
who collect interesting drug experiences
or psychedelic experiences but don't
seem to experience or resolve any deeper
healing what do you think separates
those those two groups and how how can
you increase the likelihood of real
feeling real deep healing occurring
well then extremely significant is the
concept of set and setting that means
who gives it to whom under what
circumstances for what purpose you know
that makes a big difference I have seen
people who have taken LSD hundred times
and they didn't discover that it had
something to do with their own psyche it
was like going to the movies they kept
their eyes open and you know things were
floating around check people were making
funny faces like a curious kind of
interesting experience but they had no
idea that the way they perceive the
environment is actually a result of the
projection from their own unconscious so
the one major difference is do you keep
your eyes open I walk around let alone
driving cars what people have been doing
and so on you know or doing it in the
raves where it's an open place where
people don't know what they are taking
and the police my name they know they do
something forbidden police made sure
this is the worst possible set and
setting so you increase tremendously the
risk of these experiences Annie Rudy's
they reduce the potential mm-hmm
so that's that's important so if you
come if you come with an intention the
self exploration Ealing for me for my
first LSD session it became a spiritual
quest when every every one of my
experiences I had about maybe you know
140 idols psychedelic sessions over the
years it might seem like a lot but it's
expanded over extended over a period of
60 60 years so if you look at it that
much you know it's not that much so that
is extremely extremely important but
what is your intention do you it is
serious intention or self exploration
self eating is it part of your spiritual
quest or I are you doing it for for
kicks you know because it's sort of
funny weird weird experience there's
also something that used in Smith's set
which was very interesting
there was this whole discussion about
instant-on or chemical mysticism when we
saw in the early LSD session that people
had mystical experiences then this whole
question of chemical mysticism Kramer
what what is it what are we watching and
there was what a group of people who was
nerdy sort of hardcore material
scientists as well here you have it what
this Mystics thing are some kind of deep
insights into ontology and cosmology is
nothing else but aberrations of body
chemistry so so much for mysticism so
much for spirituality it's all chemistry
and there was another group that was
saying no what is happening there is a
very special group of chemicals that can
induce mystical experiences those are
sacred
substances those are sacraments those
are sacred medicines and so on so they
took basically the position that the
shamans of native cultures took who were
using psychedelic plants like your turn
on a cattle you know the flesh of the
gods and so on the plants either were
deity so they had them mediated access
to two deities and there was this
position also the third position was the
mystical experiences in use bicyclists
are phenomenologically indistinguishable
from those that are described in
spiritual literature but they don't have
the same value to have really valuable
mystical experience it has to be a
result of prayers of meditation or it
has to come as a grace there's no way
you can take a pill and experience God
so people like Meher Baba and so on the
you know very very negative guy called
Zaire in in a British British television
and so on so this will put it sort of in
the in the court of spiritual teachers
to say artists variable or not and there
was disagreement all the tibetans for
example that I have known and actually
been in around some of them when they
had sessions they all valued it very
much as something that that is
accelerating your spiritual spiritual
development but just caution that this
is very this is very powerful that you
said to be done very very carefully on
the other hand then Buddhists usually
had difficult experiences with
psychedelics because you are not
supposed to pay attention to what's
happening it's called Macchio if you
just your past life experiences you know
you're supposed to sit through it and
cut into the no mind place it's very
difficult to have 300 micrograms and not
to pay attention to what is if you just
cut
you know to it no mind place and then
this is the I'm back now to use in Smith
Houston Smith said even one like mayor
Baba all the in a head actually
experiences he came to us to Baltimore
you know for a session we had that the
possibility of giving sessions legally
to people who were ministers during
passed or account counseling and so on
I actually was in in one of his one of
his sessions so he knew what he was
talking about and he said the
chemically-induced s-- mystical expenses
are phenomenologically indistinguishable
this was already shown in Peng Keys Good
Friday experiment in the marsh Chapel of
the Boston University very famous
experiment Good Friday experiment that
you I know you talked about in your
discussion with Michael Pollan and just
to define very quickly I apologize for
people who are listening for a
phenomenal phenomenal logical or
phenomenology that's the subjective
report yes if you look at the subjective
experiences of people who had them
through LSD or psilocybin and you
compare it with what you what you read
about in spiritual literature
so that's phenomenologically
indistinguishable but he said but the
value would be very different depending
on the set engine setting he said if
let's say you have a situation there is
a party in Berkeley oh and the way it
was done and there would be a fruit
punch and a joker comes with a handful
of sugar cubes laced with LSD people
think they are drinking punch and you
know this they out of their gourds this
nobody who's holding the Christ drink
and so on even under these lousy
circumstances sometimes it can happen
that people would have mystical
experiences but it would be completely
out of context they would not know what
to do we had difficulties to integrate
it and become a kind of very likely
alien ankle
in their in their life if it is somebody
who is a spiritual seeker who reads
literature who is doing systematic
meditation and then now here's that this
could accelerate and it would do the
sessions you know in a proper set and
setting the context in some kind of a
reverential attitude and would do then
afterwards after the sessions some some
reading and continue working on it in
meditation this could become a really a
powerful catalyst of spiritual journey
and I think that's that's the correct
answer you know see you've mentioned
seekers and a number of names a friend
of mine recommended I don't even know
this name and I may be a shame that I
don't but it recommended that I ask you
about your experiences with Swami
Muktananda and I don't recognize that
name but I thought that this is as good
a time as any to perhaps bring it up if
if you if you can answer that yes it
became kind of quite important figure in
in our lives I met him first about 1965
when he was on his second tour around
the world he was the head of the of the
Siddha yoga movement during the first
trip around the world he was actually
accompanied by Ram Dass and by by Verner
Earhart and again my my late wife
Christina she came to one of his early
session he came to Honolulu and she
became a devotee of his and so when we
when we connected she wanted me to meet
Muktananda and arrange this this darshan
with him in in Auckland and I described
this experience and some later
experience again in a couple of chapters
in the book when the impossible happens
and it was very interesting I was very
reluctant you know to go I was not a
guru purse
I would was not sort of somebody would
be you know identifiy tough somebody I
had the feeling that ultimately it was
between me and the cosmos and so on but
we had about 20 minutes waiting for for
that darshan and at that point she told
me that he was a Shaivite this is a four
you know a follower of Shiva and I had
some of my most powerful experiences in
my sessions with the the archetype of
Shiva sort of various ways and this sort
of changed my feeling about this to be
interred find somebody I knew that
shaivites using all kinds of means
including Bank you know hashish and so
on and and also that aura so they have
is a very highly experiential group and
so this change suddenly my attitude to
this for this interview and I walked in
and he he was sitting there you know was
a red ski cap with dark glasses holding
a when the wand of peacock feathers sent
it with the central oil and have a
called loogie which just looked like a
night night shirt and he sort of
beckoned me not to come
you sit here it would be chair just by
him and he turned my head and was sort
of took off his took or or sort of
shifted up his dark glasses which he
very seldom did and he sought looked
into my eyes like he was an
ophthalmologist you know and the first
thing that he said is you're a man who
has seen Shiva he says this is very good
and this just blew my mind I just
finished you know the describing my
experiences which with Shiva and the
fact that this was a very important
figure and the first thing that he says
you know I can tell you if seen Shiva
and so we had we had this long interview
where I actually asked him about Psalm
which I was fascinated by this is the
this psychedelic plan that was used you
know in ancient India and described in
Rig Veda but one hundred over hundred
stanzas in Rig Veda are dedicated to
soma it was a plant and there was a
beverage that was produced and some of
the descriptions showed that those were
powerful psychedelic you know half of us
is on earth half of us in heaven we have
taken soma so we knew that there was a
powerful psychedelic but they the secret
was lost and so I asked him and said oh
yeah you know with on my birthday the
Vedic priests come down to the ganesh
puri and they do a so much ceremony and
you can come as my gift guests you know
i will introduce you and then he died
before we could actually do it so to
make a long story short then we were
walking out of this his room and was
standing at the door and he looked at us
and says you come to our intensest we
have to intense intensives of kashmir
shaivism
which is this kind of a Mahayana branch
of Buddhism that started in Kashmir when
in the eighth century rishi had a vision
of some rocks near Srinagar and he went
there and exposed some cover of
vegetable cover and they were
inscriptions carved in the rock that
became then the shiva sutras this was
like the bible of kashmir shaivism
so he said come this is on Kashmir
Shaivism he looked at me and says this
will be very important interesting for
you and so of course we did and when I
listened to the Swami who started
describing what Kashmir Shaivism
was I had the feeling that he was
stealing you know sentences and
paragraphs from
an article which I had written izing
1969 which was called psychedelic
ontology and cosmology observations from
LSD sessions so the interesting question
what you know what is the common
denominator between experiences that
people have with LSD this strange
substance that Swiss chemist discovered
in in Switzerland and something that was
found written on on the rock in Srinagar
in the 8th century and so then we
started sort of going to these
intensives whenever we were we need to
Muktananda and then we actually did a
large transpersonal conference in in
Bombay or Mumbai this was 1982 which was
on ancient wisdom and modern science
bringing together spiritual teachers and
people from the new paradigm circles
like reach of reach of Capra and you
know others so that was our Boston our
history what we've mentioned we've
mentioned the title you know when the
impossible happens a few times I figure
we might as well jump into it and
discuss certainly perhaps the reasons
for writing the book but also some of
the stories I would imagine well I would
love to hear some of the stories and I
would imagine people listening would
love to hear some of the stories as well
well Tim what happened to us that our
house in Mill Valley burned down in in
2001 and I lost my whole referential
library so it was difficult to write
books like I used to where you have to
refer to people's work and and take
passages of it and so on and so I
decided to write a biography but you
know my life has been pretty pretty
intense pretty rich so the question was
you know what do I select and then I
decided to select observations and
experiences from my life that current
material science would consider it to be
impossible this this is not not possible
if the material stick
is accurate so I selected them so it's a
selected of selection of these stories
and about one third of this is dedicated
to amazing synchronicities that I have
experienced in my in my life and some of
the synchronicities were actually
related to Muktananda so there are two
chapters of it describing what happened
between us and and Muktananda what is
the synchronicity
well synchronicity is something that
Carl Gustav Jung brought in to the to
the attention of Western scientists
after hesitating for twenty years
collecting for twenty years
observations because you realize this is
against this is undermining the
cornerstone of metric science where the
basic principle is linear causality you
know the what we experience is a chain
of linear causality everything that
happens as a course and has an as an
effect and this works in western
material six science with the exception
of the the course of causes you know
what what caused the beginning of the
universe there we we don't go there very
frequently because we don't have any any
good answers for that now what he showed
up that there are situations where
there's a meaningful correlation or
connection between something that's an
intrapsychic event like like a dream or
a vision or a psychedelic experience and
something that happens in material
universe MIDI in the material universe
or what we call so-called objective
reality consensus reality and now this
should not be happening I mean our
psyche should be reflecting the material
universe which is out there it should
not get into a kind of playful
interaction with it okay so let me just
give you a couple of major examples from
from from that book I am referring to
the experience that I had with Joseph
Campbell again you know great great
mythologist
greatest mythologist over the twenty
essentially probably of of all time and
he used to come regularly to Esalen and
do workshop and even to our workshop
manslaughter workshops and so on and we
were doing some workshops with him and
in one of these workshops he was talking
about young he was you know great
supporter and and and very enthusiastic
about about young and he mentioned
synchronicity and somebody didn't
understand it and said Joe could you
explain what synchronicity is and he
first gave this official definition of
Young's you know this is a meaningful
connection across time or space between
an intra psychic event and something
that happened in the material world but
he says I will give you an example he
said you know we were living in downtown
Manhattan on the 14th floor of a
high-rise building and my office had two
sets of windows one was overlooking
sixth Avenue which was you know not
nothing interesting that met like many
streets in Manhattan but the other set
was overlooking the Hudson River and
that was a beautiful view so these two
windows were open all the time the
others we were open just for cleaning
nobody was bothered to open those
windows and then he said and at the time
I was working on the first volume of
what was supposed to be world mythology
and it's called
the way of the animal powers and that
first volume is about shamanic
mythologies of the world and then joe
said and i was working on the chapter
about Kalahari Bushmen this is in
Bushmen you know living in the Kalahari
Desert and he said in their mythology a
major heroic figure is praying mantis
and so I my desk was covered with papers
and pictures related to the mentis and
the Kalahari Bushmen and there was
lauren under posts book about his
childhood when he
a Bushman nanny and he learned and I
post described how this nanny was seemed
to be communicating with the was a
praying mantis that they were having
sort of conversations and you know when
the with the movements the the praying
mantis seemed to be responding to him
but to her and then said in the middle
of this work I suddenly had this totally
irrational impulse to go and open one of
the windows that we never open and I
stuck my head out and turn it
automatically to the side and there on
the 14th floor of high-rise building on
Manhattan there was a great specimen of
a praying mantis sort of climbing up the
the building and turned her his head
toward Joe and he said I took a close
look and the way when their pose
described it was true it there was
something that make the praying mantis
looked like a Bushman so anyway so
that's the that's historic and so you
know it's possible to imagine that
somehow praying mantis got into
Manhattan somebody has it is a pet or
whatever in it you know it got to that
place so but that it in itself is not
very probable happening but the fact
that it happened you know in such a way
that at the time when Joe's head was
filled with thoughts about praying
mantis and so on and he had this
irrational impulse to go and open the
window that he never opened and he looks
out and you know there is that right
there is a praying mantis and actually
turns toward him and gives him a meat
got what he felt was meaningful look
that's pretty mind-blowing synchronicity
so you know young hesitated 20 years
before he presented it 1951 in in one of
the era knows conferences and it was
presented together with a talk by
Wolfgang Pauli one of the founders of
quantum physics who was first Jung's
patient and then a very close very close
friend
let me just to quickly give you another
example which is the most mind-blowing
synchronicity from my life yes please
this happened during our first trip to
China where we were bringing
transpersonal psychology and holotropic
breathwork to China and we did workshop
a roadtrip aggressor workshop in Jinan
which is the birthplace of of Confucius
and we were having dinner and one of the
participants came to me and since then I
had an experience about you in my dream
last night
and I said what was it and she said it
was my great grandmother who showed up
and told me that we have an important
stone in our family for generations and
that stone should go to dr. groph so she
actually brought it she was holding a
beautiful beautiful blue velvet bag and
opened it and it was a fossil Nautilus
the ammonite you know which are they
that are the ancestors of the Nautilus
very very beautiful for sure now and the
interesting thing was that it was picked
up at the top of Mount Everest I didn't
know at that time that it's possible
that this is a marine mollusk you see so
it comes from the bottom of the ocean
and it's some it got during the creation
of Himalayas got to the top of Mount
Everest now what is interesting about
this that when I started transpersonal
psychology International Association of
transpersonal psychology and the series
of international conferences we were
thinking what would be the proper logo
for the International Transportation
Association and we came up with the with
the chambered nautilus you know which is
a beautiful piece of sacred geometry so
for decades we were using it on the
stationary it was on all the programs of
transference and psychology so you know
here we are bringing transpersonal
psychology to China and
great-grandmother shows up in the dream
of a woman who actually was called Ming
which is the Chinese name for dream and
tells her to bring me this this fossil
Nautilus you know which was taken from
the bottom of the ocean to the top of
the of the highest mountain in the world
according to the estimates the Himalayas
were born about about 50 million years
ago during the collision of the of the
tectonic plates so this was a you know
at least 50 million years old fossil
Nautilus you know symbol of the
International transpersonal Association
so of course the Chinese press you know
didn't describe how great that
holotropic breathwork was but they all
focused on this incredible synchronicity
you know are there are there any other
stories or phenomena experiences that
are difficult to explain in that book or
outside of one the impossible happens
that are related to psychedelic sessions
well there are of course experiences of
the out-of-body experiences in
near-death experiences you know where
people who are in a state of clinical
death cardiac death or even a flat EEG
have experiences they might be watching
the the procedure from from the ceiling
so that when they were brought back to
consciousness they are able to describe
the the procedure there's one case where
this was happening to a woman who had to
be frozen because they needed
to get to the tumor at the base of the
skull and so she had fled
electrocardiogram fled
electroencephalogram and at the same
time this is the most detailed
description of the of the surgical
procedure that we have where she was
able to to draw the instruments that
they were using and so on so there are
many many of these and we had we had a
couple of those experiences with our own
cancer patients so this one of them is
described in the book there is there is
one chapter which I called
unorthodox psychiatry where people
experienced healing in connection with
experiences that you know wouldn't make
any any sense to current psychiatrists
what would be an example of that so
there was one situation where we had a
five day workshop at Esalen and a woman
came who had for the last two years had
had very bad depression which
psychiatrists would consider to be
what's called endogenous which of course
doesn't mean anything and endogenous
Mincy generated from within but the
characteristic is that it's worse in the
morning so she got out of the bed and it
took her like a couple hours before she
managed to brush her teeth and and you
know get dressed properly and so on so
she had two sessions with us which we
had in the five days at Esalen and you
know they were pretty powerful things
from childhood and she was reliving her
birth but Friday in the morning which
was the last day she came and she
actually experienced some
intensification of these feelings so we
asked her to lie down we had a different
different program for that morning adore
the conclusion of the five days but it
was clear that we had to do something so
she lie down in the in the middle of the
room
and we just told her just to go with the
experiences this she didn't even do more
breathing and she again completed a
little something but the experience of
the births biological birth and then
went it went into this very strange
series of movements were to look like
sort of a praying or worshipping some
things you end up in a in a sitting
position and then this monotonous chant
repetitive chant came in a language that
that we did not understand and this was
going for quite a while and then it
ended and she laid back and she was just
completely blissed-out
you know in a in an ecstatic state the
group was reacting in a strange way
people were ending up in their Lotus
positions you know some of them crying
for for unknown reasons and we had a
Jewish psychoanalyst from Bordeaux Cyrus
participating in this five-day workshop
and he came to us and he said this is
fantastic
do you understand what happened with it
no he said she was she was chanting in
perfect Sephardic language the Ladino
which is that medieval mixture of
Spanish and Hebrew and it happened to be
his hobby you know he was he knew the
Sephardic language and we say wow he
says we asked him what what was she
singing is what she was singing I am
suffering and I will always suffer I am
crying and I will always cry I am
praying and I will always pray now this
episode finished this two years of the
exogenous depression we saw her than a
couple of times at conferences and the
depression never came back back so the
idea of you know healing
depressions pretty bad depression by
singing a Sephardic prayer it's a pretty
unusual sort of a therapeutic mechanism
is what do you so what do you make of
that
what do you how do you explain that you
know self we we seen a lot of this kind
of thing that healing happens powerful
healing happens in the holotropic
breathwork through mechanisms that we
don't understand
I saw before you know working with
people who were in psychoanalysis so on
the opposite that people after years of
psychoanalysis they got to the point
where they can give you lectures why
they have the problems how is it related
to early cannibalism and the you know
the toilet training and her deepest
problems only the problems don't change
very much so you are saying you have the
option either have a very little result
with what seems to be intellectual
understanding or a result where you have
no clue what and in that particular
experience with the Sephardic chanting
that was with that was following breath
work but not using any type of dosing of
an L type of material no you are careful
not to bring in people not to bring
anything into the you know the oral
tropic breath work sessions because it's
the structure is completely different
the timing of the breath work is
different about three hours and the type
of music that we use so it would not be
it would not be great set and setting
it's not it's not structured for a
psychedelic experience and actually this
would you know disturb we had one
situation actually where somebody who
had black belt took it going into our
our workshop at a salon without telling
us and ended up you know in a pretty
aggressive situation
and it just really disturbed the whole
the whole session with a hard time sort
of you know bringing him bringing him
down sounds terrifying
I just been matter of principle you know
mm-hmm
was it illegal but it just does not does
not work well in a context that it's
created for holotropic breathwork if you
had to answer the question and there
might not be an answer to this or there
might not be an affirmative answer and
to the question that someone posed to me
which was they hadn't experienced
holotropic breathwork and they asked but
they did have a lot of research
experiment experience with psychedelics
and they asked what psychedelic at what
dose is most similar to the effects or
the experience of holotropic breathwork
well it would be more something in the
category of MDMA in that the holotropic
breathwork can create visions you know
visual experiences but it not that
common as it is in in LSD or in
mescaline where you have gonna have you
know really fantastic fractal displace
of colorful images and so on and the
whole session could be could be very
very visual in the breath work is more
like MDMA where you have something
that's almost like on the interface
between vision and a vivid thought and
so on and if if we were to look at
another subjective experience that's
reported with with decent regularity
with psychedelics specifically entity
encounters and this seems to be
frequently reported with say ayahuasca
or Smith say say it once more into the
encounters encountering entities that
that well Jung should be subjecting
themselves seems to be quite common with
ayahuasca or smoked DMT ññ DMT
specifically
I what is have you seen this in breath
work and also do you make any attempt to
interpret what these things mean or is
it really left to the person
experiencing it to integrate it or to
heal through such a perceived encounter
or something that exists independently
well this you know this was described of
course with with peyote mescal Ito right
mezcal eaten and also very common with
ayahuasca and intoa Pachamama right the
bottom you know mother and so on the
only time I had it was in an ayahuasca
session where there was a sense of
actually it's not true I had it once in
in an LSD LSD session where there was a
presence there was a energetic presence
I didn't see you know a figure but there
was also communication which was
telepathic which was without words this
was very strange because this was at a
time when we had close boundaries we
couldn't even initially travel to Russia
let alone to to the west and there was
this kind of entity appearing in my LSD
session I was like a genie almost like
asking you know what would you like your
your life to be like and I said I would
like to see the world I would like to
understand psychosis this was the place
I was in and I would like to have a job
that's not a kind of a nine-to-five job
I would like to have some kind of a
freedom and the answer was okay but your
task is to bring spirituality to Eastern
Europe and to Russia I said now I really
did it you said now I'm flipping out I
can't you know I can't even travel to
the Poland and this is promising me I
can see the world but then of course it
it happened you know then
it's developing transpersonal psychology
and became very very popular in in
Russia and then 25 years ago bringing
trans person psychology to to
Czechoslovakia actually so so that was a
fascinating synchronicity again and then
I had won in the ayahuasca session but
also this was a this was a very intense
but but it was guiding my session was
was sort of telling me what I should
look look at how I should handle it and
that's not something that you observe in
in breath work very often no yeah no you
know I actually wrote initially I wrote
that I consider psychedelics to be
nonspecific amplifiers yes
when I and it would have to be modified
I actually all psychedelics can take you
to the areas which I described in that
cartography you can experience something
from from child's sufficiently important
emotionally you can relive your birth
you can have prenatal experiences even
this is a I almost hesitate to say that
reliving your conception you know
identifying with on a cellular level
with the sperm and the and the ovum you
can have past life experiences you can
have archetypal experiences you can it
can take you to the collective
unconscious and so on so the cartography
applies to all of them but there is a
different style in which it's coming you
know let's talk about more more visual
less visual and so on more emphasis on
on physical feelings or on the emotions
in certainly MDMA or some some of the
other antigens they are shifted how a
spectrum towards a positive there are
very few people who have bad trips or
MDMA MDMA is very dangerous
physiologically but very very easy for
most people to to handle psychologically
emotionally
but then I discovered this this element
in ayahuasca that there is very
frequently the imagery of the Amazonian
jungle or the anaconda snake is coming
the kind of a roto-rooter you know
cleansing Jaguars images of Jaguar so
there is some kind of a selectivity
thought from the collective unconscious
is actually prevalent in in those
sessions do you have any opinion or
opinion of or experience with micro
dosing of different psychedelics has
that something you've administered to
people or I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it it's become a topic okay I had it
quite quite a few of like that 25
micrograms you know for for hiking or
swimming in the ocean or something that
just enhancement of the of the
perceptual experience of the world but I
haven't experimented with the with the
smoke I had lots of very interesting
experiences inside of the sessions and
then particularly coming down from the
sessions when I was in a kind of a state
that would that you might be
experiencing on lower dosages but it was
at the end of a high dose session rather
than an experience per se what did you
experience at the tail-end of the
sessions what were they yeah what were
what were those experiences at the
tail-end of those high dose sessions
that that were interesting well there
were you know all kinds of psychological
insights from a lot of the things that
I've been writing about you know we're
combinations of what I saw in the
patients and then getting insights and
understanding even in the in the high
dose as parts of the sessions when I hit
some difficult places like for example
existential despair feeling you know
there's no meaning in life absurdity of
life and so on which
very frequently happens in during your
living of births when you get to what I
call the second a perinatal matrix which
is the stage of births where the uterus
contracts but there is no opening the
cervix is not open so you have the
feeling of total you know existential
despair total bummer there's no no
meaning everything is absurd we go from
nowhere to nowhere we come to this world
naked crying in pain you know without
any possession and this is how we're
going to end no matter what you do in
your life or with your life those are
really heavy kind of experiences so I
had some of those experiences when
either there is a suicidal impulse or
even suicide even suicide would not be
solution of trying to get out of that
state and so when I was hitting some of
these places in my own sessions I would
have like a parade of my patients where
I would suddenly say oh this is where he
was or this is where she was when I was
when I was bringing just my training as
a psychiatrist and things that I've read
I realized I was sitting there listening
to what they were saying I had no clue
what what they were talking about and
but I got really full experience real
understanding by finding those places in
myself and this is also interesting
about this this large map of the psyche
you know that each of us has all those
things it's not a question of whether
you are a psychiatric patient or know if
you go deep enough you you find all
those elements within yourself
it's if you if you are dealing you are
processing the hours in the birth canal
you find the whole psychopathology there
all the emotional problems all the
psychosomatic symptoms the choking the
the north the the headaches the the pain
psychosomatic pains in the body you know
people frequently tell me they found
Hitler inside they found Stalin I mean
you discover the shadow aspect so so the
the human personality is a little
different from what's described by
mainstream psycho
today would you you and your late wife
Christina coined the term spiritual
emergency and she found it I guess 1980
the spiritual emergence Network Sen now
I'd love for you do explain what that
means but then also if you could also if
you could touch on the difference
between or differences if there are any
between spiritual emergencies that are
naturally occurring let's just say or
what people might view is the onset of
schizophrenia in the late twenties or
something like that yeah versus those
precipitated by psychedelics well that
concept came from in the work with
psychedelics and with the with the
breath work you know when you realize
that people in these situations would
have experiences like death rebirth
destruction of the world recreation
recreation of the world past life
experiences and so on and I very early
discovered that there was if you have
bad trip there's no way no good way of
terminating it the worst thing that you
can do is what's done routinely which is
come with tranquilizers when you give
tranquilizers to people who are in it on
a bad trip and then keep them on
maintenance dosages this prevents any
kind of resolution if somebody has a bad
trip that means that they are dealing
with a difficult aspect of their
unconscious and when it's coming up it's
coming up for a healing for it's not
it's not just that the drug created this
horrible horrible experience so so the
way you do it you have to tell people
you know do you're in a the LSD session
this is a time-limited think I'm gonna
be here and then when something remains
unresolved we do some bodywork and some
emotional work to bring it to a good
closure people can benefit from these
bad trips so I realized very early that
when people had difficult experiences
the last thing I would do is to combine
with tranquilizers you know and so I saw
many of those situations where people
experienced
what they would be hospitalized for in
the psychedelic session and we free
state with it it actually was a major
healing major transformation so then the
obvious answer was you know should we
treat it differently just because it
happened without breathing or fast
breathing or because it happened without
psychedelics no we just you know applied
to that other category of spontaneously
emerging experiences of this kind now
what is necessary for having this kind
of understanding you have to have the
large map the psyche is not just the
postnatal biography and the Freudian
individual unconscious there is the
record of these hours of birth of the of
the anxiety of the of you know the
physical discomfort and also the the
amazing aggression the fury that is
generated in the fetus who cannot
breathe and is is subjected to all those
torsions and so on so if you have a if
you have a map that includes that and if
you have the map that includes the
collective unconscious which psychiatry
has not accepted the Jungian idea that
we have also the collective unconscious
as a regular kind of germane part of our
unconscious both the historical part of
the collective unconscious and the the
archetypal so having visions of
archetypal beings are being taken to
archetypal domains like hell or paradise
those are common experiences in in the
breath work or in psychedelic sessions
so this just gives you an idea this
stage that you can work with the way you
would work with people in a in a
psychedelic session so that's the
perfect segue let's take as a as a
hypothetical situation and an alternate
world where the psychologists and
psychiatrists have accepted the
collective unconscious and
have this larger map someone is brought
to a hospital
by their family because they seem to be
having what the family believes to be a
psychotic break
whether it's schizophrenic or die
however it might be diagnosed currently
they're brought to the hospital if a if
a practitioner if a doctor or
psychologist has larger map what would
the intervention or diagnostic process
look like potentially well people people
usually ask me when I say that the
concept spiritual emergency if there are
any professional psychiatrist
psychologist they say can you give me
differential diagnoses you see this is
what we did in somatic medicine
differential diagnoses you see people
have you know infection you want to find
out which infections what is the
differential diagnosis what is the
differential diagnosis between different
kinds of diabetes and so on so they
would like something like that for
spiritual emergency which you cannot do
because the you know psychosis is not
this is not a medical diagnosis we we
can't in the exception of the organic
psychosis we cannot really make the
diagnosis we don't have any findings in
the cerebrospinal liquid we don't have
any findings in the blood we don't have
any finding in the urine where we can
you know have a litmus paper put it in
the sample of your instance it comes out
you know green its schizophrenia right
you basically the diagnosed these
different psychotic so called psychotic
states by the fact that people have
experiences and behaviors that current
model cannot but but part of those
symptoms which are which are used as
being important you know diagnostic
tools for for psychiatry could be for
example people have the experience of
death rebirth the destruction of the
world recreation of the of the world
they have experiences that seem to be a
past life experiences so those are all
absolutely
normal elements in the human unconscious
but other understood really in if you
want in the graffia and Jungian way the
psyche is infinitely larger than then
mainstream psychiatry ever considered
it's more like the description that you
find in the great spiritual philosophies
of the East and Hinduism Buddhism Taoism
they have the they have the real maps of
the psyche because they were focusing
you know for centuries on systematic
exploration of the psyche in a very
similar way in which we do science you
know people they were describing certain
procedures that you have to follow
certain forms of meditation they would
collect the descriptions of those
experiences this disgusts right about it
and so on so it's a systematic
exploration of the human psyche these
cultures were not interested in
technology so they aren't you know
nowhere close to what we are in terms of
the understanding of the material world
but they're way ahead of us in terms of
understanding of consciousness and in
the psyche and it's very you know it's
very humbling for somebody like myself
having it you know professional training
and being through a stage when I thought
what the shamans are doing these are the
primitives in the jungle somewhere you
know illiterate and so on we have our
scientific approach which is behaviorism
or or psychoanalysis now this if you if
you have the experience of these tools
that the shamans have available you
develop a lot of respect to that and
this is related to that but the question
is did it has to be harnessed you know
and that's not an easy easy task in the
industrial civilization you would have
to change first people have to change
the paradigm which is the difficult
thing you probably know that the shift
from the geocentric system to the
heliocentric system after Copernicus you
know published
but the revolutions of the planets it
took over a hundred years and there the
the resistance it was not just the
church the resistance was coming also
from from the universities where there
are all kinds of arguments why the you
know why the Earth's cannot be around
and rotate and and you know around the
Sun and so on this for you personally
how is your experience of your inner
world changed over the last say sixty
years at or after you had your first
psychedelic experience so do you have
that experience and you go on develop
all these experiences what what is your
inner your experience of your inner
world look like well you know I was an
atheist this goes back to a little
scandal in our family when my parents
got fell in love and wanted to get
married it was in a small check town and
my father's family was had no religious
affiliation and my mother's family was
strictly Catholic and so the church
refused to marry them because my father
was a taken by their definition and this
was created a lot of turmoil it almost
seems like it would not happen until the
solution came my mother's parents made a
major donation to the church and then
suddenly they relaxed their standards
and they allowed that and they had a
business on Main Street and so when when
the wedding happened they could roll out
carpets across the street stop the
traffic and to take the carpets to the
to the altar so the guests could go from
the altar all the way to the house and
ever banquet there and my parents got so
upset by this that they decided not to
commit me or my brother to any religion
we should make our own decision when we
come of age so we actually eight classes
of religion but for me it was always
less three-hour I would go for a walk or
the book or they were sort of playing
soccer somewhere I would join them you
know being glad that I had this extra
time but also I was a very curious
creature but I was also missing this was
called I think paradesi and morale or
something like these were the classes
and David they were being taught
something that I was missing so I was
kind of a little ambivalent about it but
then from this kind of background I went
to medical school at the time when in
the Marxist regime we were controlled by
the Soviet Union so we really got the
pure materialistic doctrine you can't
you can't get you know more
materialistic than that so it was my
first LSD session that just changed that
and you know I was one kind of person in
the morning and another person walked
out of there
in the evening I was really basically
open to the to the mystical world I saw
that you know that was a much deeper
understanding that that anything that
that my formal training provided so so
this the paradox which I was aware of it
when I was coming down as a belief sort
of it not believing but a mystical you
know a mystical person I differentiate
quite a bit spirituality from religion
never became religious in any way I
became very spiritual and I realized the
paradox you know this is the divine sort
of comes to me in an experiment in a
Marxist country you know induced by this
substance from a Swiss chemist but I
knew I felt I was stuck in psychiatry
and I was at that point not very excited
about psychiatry but I felt coming down
from the session I felt if I am
psychiatry this is by far the most
interesting thing I can study so if you
look at my professional career there's
nothing there was a year 60 years you
know that I have done that would not be
in one way or another related to these
holotropic states that became
what I said was by my passion my
vocation my my profession is it is there
any particular synchronicity or
experience in any of the holotropic
states that you've experienced yourself
that that you find the hardest to
explain or the most unusual / remarkable
and does this does anything come to mind
I don't know you I have so many so many
of them I think one of your life but you
don't have to pick one yeah you could do
you can choose more than one too one of
the wildest one was actually the first
session that I had in when I came to
Baltimore from Prague it was a process
were in my request to for the
scholarship was first turned down and
then then I appealed and then I had a
very powerful psychedelic session with a
colleague of mine a psychiatrist and
this was a major major death rebirth
opening and what I experienced that you
know kind of Atman Brahman experience
and I came back home and in the mailbox
was a positive response I can I can go
to the United States so within very
short time I packed I ended up you know
it's 40 pounds of my luggage I took all
my records with me 25 25 pounds of 15
pounds of personal belonging and I was
going to to Baltimore and in Baltimore
we had the permission to give sessions
to professionals and collecting the
information from that and so I had a
session we you know we qualified for
that ourselves
and in that session I suddenly had the
feeling that I was not bound by space
and time that I somehow could get to
other places in the world if I decide to
and I wanted to put it to a test I said
can I for example get to Prague into
into the
compartment of my parents and so I
imagine you know which direction was
Prague and how far and imagine myself
sort of flying in that direction and I
was experience of flight but I was not
getting anywhere so I felt there was a
problem there and I was thinking about
it and then I realized that I was
limited by this by the constant this the
court in a spatial temporal coordinate I
believe that practice in this direction
you know and a certain kind of distance
that I have to overcome and just imagine
that I am I'm in Prague and what
happened the next time I was suddenly
trapped in some kind of very strange
space where they were like circuits on
or transistors to stuff and I didn't
know what was happening and then I
realized I was inside of the television
of the the you know television set of my
of my parents and I was thinking about
it and I had to laugh because I was
still holding on to the next element of
the materialistic world the only way you
can really see what's happening in other
places you need a television you need
you need a camera and a satellite you
see so I realize I'm not even bound by
that I'm in a world of spirit I can just
have to say now I am there and I am
there and then in that at that point he
turned kind of inside out and I was
walking I felt straight I did fell
didn't feel I was in a session and I was
walking in that apartment I heard my
parents breathing and I went to the to
the window and there there on the corner
was a clock and it was showing the the
six hour difference which I thought for
a while and I said not not the proof you
know I knew it that there was a
difference that my mind could fabricate
that so how do I prove that this really
happened
and I said I would go and take a picture
of the wall and then check with my
parents and it says something strange
happened you know if Abby found this
painting on the you know on the floor
and this nail was still in the wall and
so I started walking to the and reaching
for that and then suddenly I had the
feeling that I was gambling I was I was
playing like a roulette with my with my
soul that was this was very dangerous
and the feeling that I was getting sort
of under the influence of some evil
forces and then I realized how much they
warned you if you aren't a spiritual
quest from that that period where you
start playing with this mind over you
know the CDs and so on and I started
seeing I started seeing images but what
I could do if I really have that
possibility I could go and eavesdrop and
political meetings in the world you know
I could get access to scientific secrets
and so on I could go to a casino I could
be the casino and so on and I realized
there was a there was a real danger from
the ego to start playing with the
possibility of having this power so I
finally sort of didn't have the courage
to do that and also didn't want to be in
a world where this would be possible
because if I had the power then other
people had the power and then the doors
don't protect me I mean a world sort of
you know this kind of a wild Western and
I didn't didn't want that proof that
this is this was really possible
and I went I lie down on a couch were
actually I was coming down from a
session before going to to Baltimore and
I was lying then and then this horrible
thought came to me maybe I never got to
Baltimore I am just i fabricated that
trip to to the United States in my LSD
session I'm now coming down from from
the session I never left you see so I
was like
trunks who in that situation you know a
my butterfly having the dream of being a
human or a human having the feeling that
I am butterfly so I was stuck in that
place for a while where I was not sure
whether I was having esta projection
from Baltimore or whether I was I was
coming down from the session so that was
the wildest one probably and of Courtin
coming back I was cursing myself what a
wasted opportunity for a great
experiments you know the proof astral
projection and but the fear and the
metaphysical fear that I was really sort
of you know losing my soul in that
should I start playing with these kinds
of forces that that last part of that
experience in particular sounds terrible
well the laying down or terrifying I
should say laying down on the on the
couch in Prague and wondering like you
said if the entire trip to the United
States had been a fabrication when you
came out of that experience how quickly
did it take or how long did it take for
you to realize that in fact you were
back in the United States Oh like you
know that probably was in eight hours so
I was it was absolutely clear you know
read back to Canada yeah yeah yeah if if
you were starting your career just just
a few more questions
you've been so generous in their time
but if you were starting again right now
and you are a promising young scientist
you could research anything you wanted
let's assume that all these compounds
are legal what would you focus on what
type of studies would you want to do or
what type of research would you want to
do well you know what one of the
problems with this Renaissance that a
lot of is is have repeating things which
were already done like the cancer
projects are great but but we did it to
the point when that when we asked for
more money for continuing the research
they say you have already proved it now
it has to go to the hospital star has to
be used and
so you know those also this wonderful
study at Johns Hopkins it's just a more
sophisticated and methodologically
better your Walter panky experiment
which had some flaws certainly but I
would love to see this now going to the
research of creativity to bring people
you know biologist quantum relativistic
physicists and see what they can do as
you know we have indications that the
whole development of computers was
closely connected with use of
psychedelics you know people like a dark
angle Bart and and even you know Steve
Jobs and all these people made it
absolutely clear there was a statement
that all the people to one two men and a
woman who developed virtual reality were
acid heads so and this is now you know
understood is that there is a
possibility of sort of loosening somehow
the the blocks that we have in problem
solving because we are stuck with a
paradigm you know Thomas Kuhn wrote that
fantastic book the structure of
scientific revolutions showing that the
history of science is not a linear
development where we started from not
knowing anything and then each
generation added a little of the
observations and they were you know more
and more accurate hypotheses and
theories created so that what we have
now the understanding of the universe is
that is the best understanding that has
ever been in you know in any at anytime
in any society and it showed that it's
it's a joke that the development of
science breaks into these distinct
periods and each of them is governed but
what he calls a paradigm you know a way
of looking looking at the world you know
certain basic metaphysical assumptions
beliefs ways of what are relevant areas
to research how do you do research how
you evaluate it this is all paradigm
tight so
the examples of course I already
mentioned the the shift from the
geocentric to the heliocentric system
there was a one revolution in chemistry
where they had phlogiston chemistry
where there was this royal substance of
phlogiston and then when people like
like daltin or Laveau as he came with
the idea of atoms you know people had
problems because they didn't believe in
in phlogiston anymore now we laugh when
you hear that and then of course the the
first three decades in the 20th century
the physicists had to go through this
incredible conceptual Cataclysm moving
from newton first to the theories of
relativity and then to quantum physics
that even Einstein who initiated who
couldn't accept until his death so this
is this is the question of paradigm so I
believe that we are now in the period of
paradigm shift in relation to
consciousness and the human psyche
that's comparable in nature and scope to
what the physicists had to experience in
the first three decades of the 20th
century and then in a sense it can be
soon as being complementary to the
changes that already happened in the
understanding of matter you know the
quantum physicists who are my friends
said no no problems relating to my
observation it was mostly the resistance
of psychiatrists and psychologists in
would you oh one more thing one more
thing the hood yeah so there is the this
situation that Kuhn described that
during the time when you have the
science dominated by a paradigm the
scientists do what he called normal
science which is problem-solving within
the context of given parameters it's
like playing chess if you play chess you
have to follow the rules you can't
suddenly taken an inconvenient figure
throw it out of the out of the
chessboard you know and then he
describes what happens and when when up
observations come they challenge the
paradigm how is rejected initially
people are called crazy or it's called
fraud or whatever and then when it comes
keeps coming then finally it's
realization there is a problem and then
the wilder theories come and they first
they are sort of rejected and then after
a while the new paradigm emerges and is
accepted by the scientific community and
then history is rewritten because now
you have new heroes people who already
saw it you know centuries ago the way we
see it now but what I would like to add
was then Gregory Bateson added another
thing you see not only these do the
scientists believe in in that paradigm
are committed to it but they believe
that it's an accurate and exhaustive
description of reality per se not a map
not the best way we can sort of
currently organize the observation that
we have it is a definitive description
of how things are and this is a this is
called a confusion between the map and
the territory people like Arthur Cora
sips key and then Gregory Bateson was
very very big about it and Gregory was
laughing about it he says if scientists
make errors like that it can happen that
one day they come to the restaurant and
they eat the menu instead of the dinner
the relationship between a paradigm you
know and the territory that he described
is that is very much like reading the
menu so I've had this question I wanted
to ask this entire conversation since we
first started speaking and let me just
get my facts straight before I ask it
are you currently 87 is that accurate
what is your current age I just wanted
and 1st of July I just was was 87 87
well happy belated birthday and you go
thank you very much you are
remarkably I meet the incredibly sharp
incredibly energetic I mean more so than
some 20-somethings I know what do you
attribute that to I mean and to what
factors I mean are both we're both of
your parents sharp their entire lives I
mean I aspire currently I'm 41 41 and I
would love to have half the energy that
you do so what do you attribute that
it's it's really just I mean
mind-blowing to me to me I'm so inspired
I just trying to absorb some of those
gasm an energy that you have in this
phone in this phone call I think you
know part of it is that I'm really
really very very deeply committed to
this to this idea of these holotropic
States to bring them into psychiatry to
bring them into society I had a lot of
you know meetings with other Hoffman who
who was talking about new allowances to
create a situation where these are
integrated into social fabric they are
socially sanctioned that we can sort of
use it the way ancient Greeks did they
allow this mysteries
you know you probably know this was done
for 2,000 years in Alevis so they had to
offer something pretty impressive to
keep the attention of the ancient world
and the list of people who have been
initiates in these mysteries it reads
like who is who in antiquity I mean it
includes Plato Aristotle Cicero wrote
about it you know Marco's already who's
pinned arrows all these people so we all
sort of say you know the Greeks are very
talented beautiful art beautiful science
and great ideas no the fact that you
know so many people every five years at
some powerful experiences puts it into
somewhat different perspective and
Albert Hofmann and Gordon was
the one who brought the the mushrooms
from Mexico from the Mazatec Indians and
Karl Rock a Greek scholar they wrote the
book wrote to Alexis when they found out
that the key to this mysteries was Kiki
on KY k EO n and they found out that
this was a psychedelic potion which was
made of of our goat very similar to LSD
so it can imagine so many people every
five years in that small world had
psychedelic experiences that it could
have had some impact on the on the
culture you know the last time when we
were in in Alexis there was a guide and
there are the the ruins of of the talus
tree on which is the building where this
was happening and it's a gigantic
building and I asked how many people
were having these experiences here at a
time he said at least you know in the in
the last stage three thousand people
every five years we're getting this this
dose of this so when I when I read Plato
now I don't see him like pacing in the
academy and saying let me see how the
world works you know we have not does
this but there's this level of them with
the archetypes and so on this is
something that you can explore and
experience archetypes in psychedelic
session so these are all all the
philosophy was inspired by by
psychedelic experiences what do you what
do you think humanity needs most right
now in your opinion if humanity big
question yeah what what what do you
think humanity needs most right now what
we need yeah if there's any play other
type of change or shift there you know
Ivan magic well we I think you know the
monastic materialistic paradigm I think
it's really destroying this this planet
and we have you know we have lost
experiential spirituality that people
have really the experience to have
have spiritual experiences which are
nondenominational which are non
chauvinistic non-sectarian which are
universal all inclusive all or embracing
to people who have these these direct
spiritual experiences they they don't
experience division in the world you
know the what happens with the with the
great organized religions is that they
unite people who are willing to see it
the same way and worship the same way
but at the same time divide the world
because they set it against another
group which has taken sort of different
archetypes and different different ways
of worshipping so then you have a
situation where you know we are
Christians you all other guys are pagans
and this we really have to convert you
or it's really not a good place for you
here or we are Muslims and you guys all
are infidels let go--let have sacred
word against the infidels you know we
have juice you are going and so on and
then you have even discuss of divisions
within the same religion there's
centuries of bloodshed between
Protestants and Catholics and you have
the same with the Sunnis and the Shia
that they killing each other destroying
their own temples now these are not
religions that will help us in the
situation in the world but this is very
different with the spirituality which is
really taking taking everything in and
it changes changes you know
consciousness in a way that people
embrace the the ecological movement they
realize we have to treat nature in a
different way because we are so vitally
embedded in an entangled in in nature
that we will not use nature as commodity
you know something that should serve us
and the expense of you know destroying
destroying our environment this is you
know nothing that's more important for
us we are biological creatures we need
air we
in water and we need clean soil where we
are growing our food it's it's it's so
so suicidal so self-destructive to
destroy the basis on which we depend as
a you know there should not be anything
keeping the environment supporting life
no no you know economic profit no no
political no military order we should
really realize that we are in the same
boat and you know whoever is destroying
the environment is destroying us and
there are many places people can find of
course your writing and more about you
Stanislav Grof calm i'll link to all of
this in the show notes for people so
they'll be able to find that at tim that
blog forward slash podcast and certainly
recommend that people check out your
books including when the impossible
happens a friend of mine who's involved
in scientific research recommended I
read the cosmic game and I'm wondering
if before we wrap up maybe could you
share one more story any story that to
folks out there who are wondering if
there might be more to the story than
just the the purely material sort of a
hyper rational materialistic worldview
there might just be more to the story
I'm wondering if there's anything else
that you can share I remember the coming
across the pig goddess story I mean
there are so many to choose from but
yeah let me let me do one that's kind of
I think is you know has larger kind of
importance then than just mentioning one
one clinical story it's also a story
from when the impossible happens and it
has to do with the experience that I had
in a peyote ceremony so when I came to
the United States you know I heard about
peyote and so and I never had a chance
being in in Czechoslovakia and not
having the possibility of traveling to
have the peyote experience so I was very
interested in that and we had this
program for professionals one of the
programs at the
psychotic Research Center and the one of
the person who came was Ken Godfrey who
was the psychiatrist at the VA hospital
in Topeka Kansas he was himself you know
Native American and his wife was Native
American and he was running a
psychedelic program in in Topeka but he
didn't have anybody to sit for him so he
came for his own session and I set in
history psychedelic session so you know
we became very very close and so when
after his last session we were talking I
said Ken is there any possibility you
can get me into a Native American church
ceremony and he said I will try and then
he called in a few days and say you know
I talked to the road chief and you can
come and you can bring four of your
friends so anyway we sort of got into
the airplane and flew to Topeka and then
drove into the middle of the you know
Kansas prairie there and there were
these teepees and this the ceremony was
being prepared and we had to go through
kind of a clearance that they wanted to
find out what kind of people we were we
had to tell them about ourselves and we
got just a lot of aggressive comments
from them about how you know white
people came and they have they have
taken their land they have killed their
Buffalo that I killed they're warriors
they have raped their women and so on
and so there was a sort of almost like
an encounter group and as we were going
on they were sort of finding out that we
were okay and one after another that we
can participate and at the end there was
just one very sort of dark sullen man
who wouldn't have any of us we had me
were like pale faces and that was it you
know he's not gonna have us in the
sacred ceremony and then he gettin to a
lot of peer pressure it was time to
start and people say come on you know
let it go and so he did say yes but it
was really no and I was in the tepee I
was sitting across him and then the the
buttons peyote buttons were were
and then he started coming on and he
sort of was really like radiating like a
laser beam toward me you know the hatred
was kind of and everything was amplified
of course by the by a peyote and we were
doing the rounds when you pass a staff
and a drum and every time you get it you
can say something you can sing his song
or invite people to do something or make
a confession or whatever but you can
also pass and every time it came to him
he would grab it and push it and he just
would not participate and so with all
these rounds and we were going through
the last last round where everybody can
say something and Bob Lehi who was a
another LSD therapist from from a
Maryland working with us Helen Bonnie
and her sister Helen bonnie was our
music therapist and Walter Huston Clarke
was very famous professor of religion
and so as we were doing the last round
Walter Huston Clarke gave this you know
almost like masochistic kind of a speech
we said how wonderful it was from your
you know brothers and sisters to take us
into the sacred ceremony after what we
have done to you we have killed your
Buffalo and your warriors and raped your
women and taken your spirituality and
then somehow I don't remember except
exactly the context he mentioned means
that especially Stan here who is so far
from his native Czechoslovakia and
suddenly when he mentioned that it was
like a lightning hit this guy and he
started shaking he got up he threw
himself into my lap and put put his head
into my lap it's not what the tears were
running out of his iesson and you know
it's not out of his nose it it became
like one of our workshops doing sort of
close work with people and everybody was
watching nobody knew what was happening
and this was happening for a while and
then he got up and went back to his
place sit down and then not not talking
just sitting there and there was like a
lot of lot of pressure you know
psychology corporation people
people wanting to know what was
happening and then he said you know I
have to say something horrible I thought
you were all Americans I didn't know
Stan was from Czechoslovakia
you know the Czechs are not known as
your archetypal Raiders of the Wild West
exactly so his I I treated him as if he
were an American and I hated him through
the whole ceremony and it's just more
more than I can I can take you know and
then what's sitting there and it was
clear that something more was coming and
then he said but it's worse than that
during the Second World War I was
drafted in the American Air Force and I
was personally present in the air raid
on his city there was five days before
the end of the war there was an American
attack on Tilton that destroyed the
automobile factory there and damaged
Dilton so I said he stayed home but I
went and I killed his people our roles
were reversed and that's just too much
for me and then he got up and he went to
the four Americans there and embraced
them he says you are not my enemies you
are you are my friend he says we are all
in the same boat we if we if we hold the
old grudges we we all die we have here
all you know children of mother earth
and we have to we have to sort of really
sort of learn how to how to live which
with each other and how to love each
other and then he ended in hisses well
they believe in reincarnation as well
and for what I can say when this was
happening I might have been on the other
side and you know we were still still
under the influence of peyote so we were
all crying and sort of embracing each
other and that the atmosphere of
reconciliation was amazing I actually
told that story and at the end of the
International transpersonal conference
in Prague when I was bringing transfers
psychology back to Prague because we had
all these you know European nations that
had all kinds of grudges and really
didn't like each other like we were
occupied by Nazi Germany for six years
you know a lot of people killed ended up
in concentration camps then we had years
of communists there in so nobody liked
Russian and none of the people from the
Eastern European countries liked either
Russia or or Germany we had sort of
German and Jews there and what was
amazing that we did a large holotropic
breathwork you know before the
conference is a pre-conference workshop
and it was amazing how within within two
days I mean some of these boundaries
were were melting and you know people
embracing each other and sitting for
each other and when people were owning
their own emotional problems they
actually activated the best in other
people and in spite of language
difficulties and so on there was really
a change of the of the atmosphere from
you know all these antagonisms that were
certainly in the air at the beginning
what a wonderful story so anyway that's
my story thank you so much less less
than in forgiveness I think we could all
use lessons in forgiveness not only
towards others but towards ourselves and
I really want to express gratitude and
thanks certainly for the experiences
that I've had which have been informed
by your writing and people who have
indirectly have directly been trained by
you in some respects and to thank you on
behalf of no doubt many people who are
listening we've had similar experiences
and not very I'm very cautiously
optimistic about this this Renaissance
that we're witnessing and hopefully we
won't repeat some of the same mistakes
that appear to have been made but the
social circumstances are so different
and
I really appreciate your taking the time
today I've been certainly hope this
isn't our last conversation but I want
to be respectful of your time and we've
gone for quite quite a bit already today
is there anything else you would like to
say to the people listening or asking
them before we before we end this
particular conversation you know maybe
repeat you know what Carl Gustav Jung
said and that I would really certainly
endorse that it's important that we live
our life not just sort of by responding
to what is happening outside of us but
spending some time in some kind of
focused self exploration and that can
read to inner transformation so we live
our life as a synthesis of what we see
outside and what comes from within it
would say you you get lessons from what
he called the self the higher higher
aspect of our our personalities so you
know part of the part of the problem of
the industrial civilization we lost this
this tradition of a few want of psycho
nautics all the other groups of humanity
way back probably in to the Paleolithic
they were they were using these
holotropic States for healing for you
know transformation for the main main
vehicle for ritual spiritual life they
weren't using it for a lot of practical
things as an inspiration for for art and
so on so I see this this tremendous
renaissance that is happening now not
just as correcting of these of this you
know really terrible administrative
legal mistakes that we're done that stop
the research for 40 years return to the
research I see it also as the
possibility of the industrial
civilization to join the rest of
humanity that always was combining
somehow the these spiritual inner spirit
spiritual experiences with whatever they
were doing in the in the external world
thank you so much again Tim thank you so
much for everything you have been you
have been doing and thank you for this
for this opportunity to you know share
some of my life with your listeners it's
with you it's such a pleasure and like I
can only aspire to contribute in some
small way and you I'm excited to see
what you do from this point forward and
you seem to have as much energy as ever
traveling around the world doing what
you do and I hope we can have many many
more conversations and but but for today
I want to be a respectful of of your
time since I you do have so many things
going on and I will certainly in the
show notes to everybody listening link
to everything we've discussed all of the
books the different websites foundations
and so on and you can find all those at
tim dot blog forward slash podcast Stan
thank you so much I really really
appreciate it again
wonderful it's great to have a an
interviewer you know who knows what we
are talking about it doesn't doesn't
always happen was one of the great ones
thank you I really really appreciate it
and to everybody listening keep your
mind open and look outside but also look
inside as Stan mentioned and until next
time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in with your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by LegalZoom which
more than 2 million Americans have used
to help start their businesses past
guests even such as well WordPress lead
developer CEO of automatic Matt
Mullenweg
now valued at more than a billion
dollars have used LegalZoom to help with
their business leads specifically in his
case to form his company but LegalZoom
isn't just for launching your business
their services include everything from
helping you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating NBA's
non-disclosure agreements important
stuff handling lease agreements and
assisting with really any other legal
challenge hurdle inconvenience that
typically takes time and effort away
from running your business the best part
is that you won't get charged by the
hour because Leo zoom isn't a law firm
so they won't be running the clock up
and spinning circles just to raise your
bill instead they just ask you to pay
one low upfront price for whatever it is
that you're looking to get Alucard style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at check up
capital T lowercase I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using for about
a year now peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right into your home you
can also do on-demand which is what I do
it will come back to that so you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
a busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute I for instance have a peloton
bike right in my master bedroom at home
and it's one of the first things I do
many mornings I wake up I meditate for a
bit then I knock out a short 20 minute
ride in my undies hard to do that at the
gym take a shower and I'm in higher gear
for the rest of the day it's really
convenient it has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes to 20 minutes
whatever music hip hop rock and roll or
say low impact vs. high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I point like Matt will
purse and I tend to do on-demand and
listen to a lot of and watch many of the
same classes over and over but I'm kind
of promiscuous and also enjoy classes
from a lot of the other instructors they
have peloton an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles and
personalities so you can find what
you're looking for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way incentive
ëismí but they really 100% hit the nail
on the head I was very very impressed
with how motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out discover
this cutting-edge indoor cycling bike
that brings a studio experience right to
your home peloton is offering the
listeners of this podcast a limited time
offer go
- one peloton calm that's both an e
peloton PE l oto and calm and enter the
code Tim all caps at checkout and get
$100 off of accessories with your Paula
so Mike purchase so get a great workout
at home anytime you want check it out go
to one peloton calm and use the code Tim
to get started
[Applause]